des rues ravagées des voitures calcinées
dans le département des Yvelines des
violences sont éclatés toute la nuit du
28 au 29 juin à Poissy des feux
d'artifice et des émeutes ont éclatés
dans le quartier de la Coudraie la ville
de trappes à quant à elle était prise
pour cible le Supermarché Carrefour des
Merisiers a été pillé le centre culturel
de la Merise a été vandalisée le
Commissariat a été pris d'assaut par des
tirs de mortiers lancés par des jeunes
cagoulés
quelques kilomètres plus loin des
établissements scolaires ont également
été pris pour cible à La Verrière deux
écoles ont été incendies l'école des Noé
et du bois de l'étang et à Guyancourt
les bâtiments d'Alembert et Vauban de
l'université Versailles Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines ont été endommagés des scènes
de chaos ont été recensés dans d'autres
communes des Yvelines à Villepreux
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles Les Mureaux
et l'encours ou encore
Chanteloup-les-Vignes au total la nuit
dernière les pompiers des Yvelines ont
dénombré pas moins de 1200 appels 45
interpellations et trois blessés légers
du côté des policiers